dans la région de zaporija un convoi
humanitaire a été pris ce matin pour
cible des civils ont été touchées en
compte au moins 25 morts et des
douzaines de blessés Moscou n'a pas
reconnu cette frappe pour le moment le
président ukrainien voulait dire
Zelinski a traité les dirigeants russes
de terroristes et de racailles
sanguinaires après la mort de ses civils
dans un bombardement on retrouve Elena
Volochine notre envoyé spécial à Kiev
quels sont vos toutes dernières
informations sur cette frappe militaire
asapoja
alors le bilan est encore en train
d'évoluer il y a quelques quelques
minutes une demi-heure à peu près il
était encore question de 25 morts et
d'une soixantaine de blessés il faut
comprendre que c'est une colonne
effectivement de voiture civile qui a
été prise pour cible les autorités
militaires ukrainiennes de zapporigia
nous ont affirmé que trois missiles S300
russes avaient été tirées et avait tué
et blessé ses jambes parmi lesquels des
enfants c'était une colonne qui
attendait là sur ce marché à la
par elle fait partie du territoire
contrôlé par les Ukrainiens qui
attendait pour passer vers les
territoires
occupés il faut comprendre que c'est le
seul point de passage actuellement entre
l'Ukraine et les territoires et tous les
territoires
occupés ou circulent d'un côté ce qui
fuit les territoires occupés vers
l'Ukraine de l'autre aussi des colonnes
de civils qui vont vers ces territoires
occupés pour diverses raisons il y en a
certains qui vont chercher leurs proches
il y a aussi tout un réseau qui
s'organise pour les Ukrainiens qui
veulent quitter l'Ukraine vous savez que
l'Ukraine empêche les hommes de sortir
et donc ceux qui veulent quitter quitter
l'Ukraine pour partir vers l'Europe et
bien passe aussi d'après nos
informations par ces territoires
occupés par la Crimée par la Russie
parfois avec des trajets extrêmement
difficiles mais enfin il y a des réseaux
de passeurs moyennant back chiches qui
les font passer par là pour pour quitter
l'Ukraine donc c'est une colonne comme
celle-ci qui a été donc prise pour cible
alors les Russes accusent les Ukrainiens
les Ukrainiens accusent les Russes mais
selon toutes vraisemblance il s'agissait
d'une frappe russe puisque ces missiles
S300 sont tombés en territoire contrôlés
par les ukrainiens et y compris sur
cette ville de zapporisia qui est un
grand une grande ville ukrainienne un
grand centre
ukrainien on a donc beaucoup de mal à
imaginer que l'armée ukrainienne aurait
tiré sur sur sa propre ville vous étiez
justement sur place hier comment sont
perçus les référendum par les Ukrainiens
qui fuient les territoires occupés
oui effectivement on était précisément à
ce point de passage où les convois de
voitures civile quittent quittent les
territoires
occupés et donc on a pu parler beaucoup
avec ces gens qui sont dans un état
psychologique très très difficile qui
sont complètement à défacer qui
s'effondrent en larmes au moment où il
quitte les territoires occupés qui
pleurent de soulagement puisque ils nous
disent avoir vécu un véritable enfer
toutes les personnes que nous avons
interrogé vraiment chacune nous parle de
cas de d'enlèvement de torture par les
autorités d'occupation et par les Russes
lorsque les les personnes qui vivent
dans ces territoires sont en désaccord
avec l'arrivée de la Russie avec
l'organisation de ces référendum avec
les nouvelles lois instaurées par ces
hommes en armes qui viennent qui
s'installe dans les maisons qui pillent
qui agissent en toute impunité et donc
on a beaucoup beaucoup de témoignages de
cas de torture à l'électricité de gens
qui disparaissent qui sont mis dans des
cas interrogés torturés vraiment
place dans ces territoires envers encore
une fois les Ukrainiens qui qui
s'opposent à ce régime qui s'oppose qui
s'oppose à cette occupation russe
évidemment pour ceux qui prêtent
allégeance à la Russie et bien ces
méthodes ne sont pas ne sont pas
employées d'ailleurs les Russes font
pression et on a pu même entendre des
témoignages enregistrés lorsque on
réunit des enseignants pour faire
pression sur eux pour qu'ils collabore
avec les Russes pour qu'ils enseignent
les programmes russes dans les écoles et
donc les méthodes les exactions les
méthodes barbares sont appliquées
parfois envers ceux qui refusent cet
état de fait aussi les Russes cherchent
beaucoup de de combattants parmi la
population et donc sans aucune sans
aucune raison peuvent arrêter faire
disparaître des gens donc ces gens sont
dans un état psychologique très
difficile et effectivement beaucoup
fuient les référendums parce qu'il
craignent qu'après l'annexion formelle
par la Russie et bien il y aura cette
mobilisation qui a décrété Vladimir
Poutine en Russie puisque il sera
annoncé que ses territoires sont
désormais la Russie et bien les hommes
pourraient être Mobilis pour combattre
ceux qui hier encore était leur
compatriotes et ça c'est vraiment le
pire cauchemar pour ces populations qui
en dernier recours décident de tout
quitter de partir vers l'inconnu de
quitter leur maison et de fuir vers
l'Ukraine merci beaucoup Léna wolochine
en direct de Kiev pour votre analyse